>> LASSEN: Okay. Federation, so this is a
pretty high-level description of Federation
and there's some pointers to some of the--some
of the next steps that we need to look at
to make the Federation protocol more useful.
And so I'm going to go through some of the--fairly
quickly go through the structure of the protocol.
I expect that some of you know it pretty well.
But let me go through it and then, you know,
anybody who's not particularly familiar with
it might be better equipped to ask the right
questions afterwards. So here, I put up some
of the dry runs from last year when we launched
this. So with Google Wave, we sort of took
an ambitious path that we've been on and said
that the Google Wave, we have something here
that could replace email. I know exactly what
the--how it looks today. But we definitely
wanted to look at communication in a, you
know, trend--in the new communication model
that address, you know. Many people use emails
today with hosted services like Hotmail and
Gmail. And there's so much that you don't
take advantage of that we wanted to explore.
So here--there's a--that's a pound when you
use one service like Google Wave right there
to take advantage of that, you know, instead
of you have--that's being an immutable copy
of the email message for each one who is on
the email thread, there's a single shared
unmutable object and that's how we can get
live typing and so on and you can edit your
message after you sent it and so on. But to
have a generally useful communication protocol,
you'd want Federation. You'd want your hosting
service to be able to talk to others. So here
are three services that you should be able
to share Waves across organization boundaries.
So when it comes to Federation Wave probably
doesn't have as much new to offer as it does
in a single hosted service, so we will look
very much at email and XMPP and other preexisting
federated protocols. And I think the Federation
protocol has a number of things in common
than model about--around some of the same
concepts, you know. You look up there, the
other guys with DNS and on. Indeed, the Federation
protocol runs on top of XMPP. And so whereas
with emails, you send these immutable emails
to each other, what you want to achieve with
Wave Federation is that you share these mutable
objects. And so the way we model that is that
it's this--the deltas that form waves are
immutable. You mutate that by appending deltas
to the--delta history. And so if you'll get--so
you share waves across Wave providers by sharing
deltas much the same way as you will email
and then you log. Everybody then composes
this and then look at the resulting waves
and that's how we share waves. Wow, that looks
terrible. Okay, well, here two Wave providers--the
message protocol is then about sharing deltas.
And a lot of this is--so we started with looking
at a single service in the time server protocol
and then we--then we built a Federation protocol
that could tie things together. And the Federation
protocol is, in some ways, simpler than the
time server protocol because we'd just share
deltas and then we count on the other end
to this of Wave server that we're talking
to and it has the power to construct--to pull
together these deltas and reconstruct the
Waves. And so, as a matter of both sort of
economy of expression and--what was the other
[INDISTINCT]--so we just share deltas. We
don't share snapshots of waves. So if on my
Wave there's a participant from another domain
that--then and is it--edit to the Wave, then
the delta goes across. So I suppose it's a
delta that adds a participant from another
domain then just that delta goes across. It
reaches that other domain, and it sees as
a delta. And if hasn't been part of that Wave
before, it can see that the version is not
so and then it turns around and asks for the
history of deltas up to that point and so
it can complete contiguous delta history up
to current. So what we--it stands here is
we--one Wave server, the host of Wave, it
broadcasts the deltas to the others. They
can turn around and request history. And so--and
I won't really cover that in this morning's
talk. So then what I didn't cover was the
security aspect of it. So when we launched
Wave just before, we had a thorough security
review. We had the [INDISTINCT] visit us in
Sydney and they looked at the whole Wave product
and then they also took a look at the Federation
protocol. Then they also said, "Hey, that
looks better than email," you know, "[INDISTINCT]
let's get some proper authentication into
the protocol." The more that they identify
that there's an extra attack vector in Wave
that makes it particularly useful to have
a proper authentication. So the thing is that--so
if you have here three Wave providers; love.com,
evil.com, and peace.com and you have somebody
from love.com and peace.com that talk to each
other, they might be talking to each other
on a Wave that's hosted in the third place.
So there's sort of a Wave provider in the
middle thing going on here. And so we wouldn't
want that Wave provider in the middle to start
spoofing messages so that if I think I'm talking
to somebody from--somebody I trust from another
domain that--I want to know that the message
came from them. And so, therefore, they introduced
then a security model here where all the messages
are signed by the author's Wave provider and
these signatures are propagated. So anything
that--somebody from love.com writes and is
propagated to peace.com, peace.com will insist
that if this is supposed to be coming from
love.com, then it must be signed by a love.com
certificate. So, yeah, the Wave server of
the author of the delta--so this is authentication
between the servers, so it's not the end user.
So the assumption here is that each Wave provider
is--should be authenticating its users. So
it's the job of the Wave provider to identify
that it's on at googlewave.com, or love.com,
or whatever on the user. And then the only
thing that is authenticated across the Federation
protocol is that information is from the server
that it's supposed to. So I use whatever secure,
authenticated connection there is between
my plan and my Wave provider. Then my Wave
provider then takes my message and signs it
with the--here, in this case, is acmewave.com
with its certificate and then it's verified
throughout. The--so if you are hosting--let's
see. So if you're--right. So if you are love.com
or peace.com in this scenario here, then you
should be--you should sign the deltas you
submit and whatever you--is broadcasted to
you from evil.com, you verify the signatures
then--are good. And it is the responsibility
of whoever hosts the Wave--it's evil.com to
host copies of the certificates. Being the
host of the Wave, it means that on the signed
deltas that are coming in from the participants--participating
domains, evil.com will want to verify the
signatures on incoming messages. So it will
retrieve the certificates that goes with them.
So if peace.com sends a delta across, evil.com
will ask for the certificate from peace.com.
And then the contract must store that certificate
in its security database, so that if immediately,
a long time later, some other party is on
the wavelet and wants to verify the history
is properly signed all the way back then they
can go to evil.com and get a certificate.
That is because who knows if it was peace.com?
Maybe that service is not running anymore
so you might not be able to find that certificate
from the source anymore. Then another piece
of the puzzle here is that the deltas that
are signed--are signed together with the history
hash, rolling hash, or the server authoritative
delta history of the Wave; that severely limits
how the Wave provider in the middle can read
all the messages. It's only up to--basically
up to what we can do with OT, meaning that
the--only when there's some simultaneous messages
being sent across can it choose to show them
in one way or the other and indeed in that
case, the participating parties, that there
is no sort of true order and things.
The transport, as I said, we use XMPP. So
the Wave server talks in Wave in a Box. The
Wave server talks, uses the--what's called
component interface of the XMPP servers to
connect to a running XMPP server. And then,
yeah, that's all in the nitty-gritty about
Discovery and so on to--that these Wave servers
sitting behind the different XMPP servers
to find each other. So this is my highlight
description of Federation. And so this afternoon,
there'll be a session where we'll talk about
both the transfer protocol and Federation
protocol and we can drill into various points
that we want to explore. But let me just sort
of put on a slide here. This is from May this
year, Google I/O. This was a list of the federated
providers at the time. So I don't know actually
how much of that is still true and where the
others are on the list now. This includes
various parties who demonstrated prototypes
of products federating.
Okay, some things that are missing from the
protocol and that we should fix in order to
make it robust enough to--we can get real,
you know, mission critical communication running
on Federation protocol is that there's--here
are a number of things that we were planning
to do but we never got around to before in
Wave precautions. One of the big things that
we think is necessary is reliable delivery.
So these messages are sent across XMPP and
they make it or they don't make it, that's
not good enough. And so this morning, I mentioned
that--how reliable messaging across the Wave
bus is necessary to build reliable indexing
and I think--and it's our belief that a similar--it's
a very similar story about Federation and
a similar mechanisms can be used. So we did
build a reliable delivery messages across
the Wave bus in the Google Wave production
systems and we were working on extending that
to Federation until we stopped. Another thing
I think is important to make Federation useful
is to have a support for groups and as Ian
also mentioned today. This is an important
aspect of a proper collaboration tool. We
were--we also have a notion of groups in Google
Wave and that was a work in progress. We were--I
had also identified this as one of the areas
that we needed to be done better to enhance
the usability of Wave and we should definitely
support that across the Federation. So we
were--we have some designs for that. They're
not--so there are various internal notes that
I can--I'm happy to share the ideas we had
about these things with anybody who's interested
to talk about it here this week. Attachments.
I think that we all--we also have some designs
for that. I think it's a relatively straightforward
problem. We could--I think we could find a
protocol for this. It's not even certain whether
you would need to change the Federation protocol
assistance or whether you could build some
conventions around that--if there's an attachment
to a Wave that you--within the Wave, the documents
in the Wave, you could provide a description
of the attachment and it could maybe be served
out by HTTPS or something like that. So...
>> So, for attachments, are we talking about
library attachments and then the attachments
have transferred to [INDISTINCT] caching or
there's a [INDISTINCT] manner or just be normalized
in the way that attachments are sort of fetched
[INDISTINCT]...
>> LASSEN: I think the best solution would
be to let the Wave providers distribute it
much like deltas and cache it for the users.
Again, if you look at the case of attachment
stuff about with some Wave provider that goes
offline one day and if others had depend on
that Wave, it would be useful to have that
cached copies around. And then...
>> From the attachment [INDISTINCT] I think
one thing to bear in mind is whether you are
actually wanting to federate the reference
to an attachment or [INDISTINCT] because,
you know, a load of [INDISTINCT] being maintained
in a repository in Google Docs or a content
manager repository, I mean, nor interested
in it [INDISTINCT] the reference to that document
and really the content if you're not really
trying to do live editing in the document
necessarily.
>> LASSEN: But--so when we talk about attachments
in waves, they were--they were, yeah, embedded
by another attachment. So I think if you want
something like that then you should, you know,
in the text of the Wave or in some structured
content of the Wave, you should write a reference
and share that. So this is about when you
actually embed a binary data in the commutable
binary data.
>> It's just like with e-mail, you can either
send the actual attachments or you just send
a link to the live document.
>> Yeah, I think...
>> LASSEN: At least we never considered the
idea of hosting an attachment that's mutable
in some way. Then there's something that came
up as we get along--around long enough. When
a year passed after the first--that one prototype
was out there, our certs start expiring and
nothing worked anymore so we always knew that
this would--will happen, that we should have--we
should do something about it but we didn't
meet the deadline. And so I believe we should,
in the spec, explain that expired certs should
be--you should host the expired certs and
host metadata about when they expire and revoked--are
revoked so that--and you see old messages
from--that were signed by certs that are expired
today that you can see that they were good
at the time.
Yeah. And then I had--I brought--from Sydney,
I brought a laundry list of the protocol bugs
and omissions that we are aware of that I
don't think we filed the issues for them.
So if anybody's actually working on a Federation
protocol, we should probably find an option
to get this week and sit together, and share
our notes on what's broken in there. Then
some other stuff. So in order to make a Federation
more useful as sort of at the end-user level,
so--but when you use the Wave panel on an
ACME Wave, and that Wave banged and so on,
these blank avatars and so on indicate, you
know, that we should find our way to get these
avatar images across. And it'll be good to
have their presence federated and so on. And
so--and on the whole, be aware that the Federation
protocol is very low level deliberately so
in that diagram of concentric circles that
Alex had at the end of his model talk. And
so the data that sets--so everything that
the Wave server does including Federation
is sort of at the lowest level. It core has
just--it's shaping our around these low level
operations and those operations transform.
And it doesn't--the Wave server is not supposed
to be known where it's talking about what's
the content of these things. And things--and
in that general principle of trying to avoid
that application level feature requirements
seep into--to the model to make--causing us
to create funny ops and stuff that cause a
lot of churn and it's difficult to check for
the greatness criteria as necessary down at
the core. Similar--something like profiles
and presence that hopefully can be done by
modeling things in waves so using other protocols,
you know, presence. You could go either way,
define presence within waves and federates
presence information, or say that it's better
to use XMPP or other presence protocols, and
provide guidelines for how the service should
tie these things together. And something that
held back us federating: Wave.google.com.
We only have federated the Wave Sandbox developer
instance. One thing that held us back was
that we were hosting all these, you know,
Google [INDISTINCT] domain. All these different
domains were hosted on that Wave.google.com
instance. And we couldn't sit around with
private keys for all those domains. So to
be--the signing was unworkable. And it's exactly
the same problem. There's something that is
relevant to the XMPP community. We want to
be able to host many domains in one XMPP.
So and they are working solutions for that.
They have something called Domain Name Assertions
where you--if you have your domain hosted
by some hosting provider with lots of domains,
then you write into your set of records and
DNS that you delegate to that other domain
to sign for your--on your behalf. And then
the hosting server just uses google.com to
see if--to sign all these many domains. And
then you--whoever wants to verify will go
to and see that each of those had--in DNS
have said that they were okay with that. And
so--yeah. But whether we want to address that,
it depends on whether we want to support these
kinds of services. And then we tie it to this
particular data type of these documents and
the participant lists in Wave search, the
other Federation protocol. It would be good
to loosen that up and I don't think it's anything
particular. So the Federation protocol ought
to be able to work with any OT data type with
their relevant properties. And this is the
last slide. I won't say much about this but--so
there's some things one could--that in principle
sounds attractive. For instance, maybe you
could share Wave faster if you just if--by
the Federation get a snapshot of the Wave
rather than pull out the potentially very
big history. And I'm not sure exactly how
that would work with the security model. So,
one could look at it but it's not clear to
me how to do it. And another thing is that
wavelets are hosted by a specific domain.
If that domain goes out of service and there
are--you know, if evil.com will shut down,
and love and peace want to keep controlling
the Wave, they can't--they'd just sit on these
copies and there's nothing to let them assume
ownership of this. And again, I don't know
how to do it but, you know, peer to peer collaborative
systems exist. Who knows? Maybe one could
modify the Federation protocols so that you
don't have this rigidity. And another thing--and
again, I have no idea where to go with this
or whether it's even useful, but this email
address style user ID's, it's that antiquated
notion, these hotwired user domain association
and the user ID is--I don't know if that was
the right way to go. We were not up for the
task of solving that problem when we--when
we built the Federation protocol. But--I don't
know what--whether there are things to consider
there, but in the long term, that might be
something to take a look at. Yup? Sorry, I
ran a lot. There'll be a session for discussion
later today but I'm happy to take some quick
questions now.
>> You take a X--using XMPP is, one the whole,
a positive for Federation or becoming an obsolete
[INDISTINCT]? Then, I know, you know, agreed
[INDISTINCT] domain.
>> LASSEN: Yeah. So it is a little bit awkward
how many hops an operation runs through in
and out of a Wave running to the XMPP and
the encoding binary encoding and stances and
XMPPs is op construction. And yeah, in Joseph's
talk, there are many things you have to configure
today to get something working overnight in
process of more and more of the good stuff.
And...
>> So there are a lot of many good paths today...
>> LASSEN: Right. So I was always asking myself
that question. I think in many ways, we successfully
got some shortcuts to getting things off the
ground this way. So in hindsight, we did the
right thing but I think it will be useful
to look at and feasible to try multiple transports
that you could do just like--you can have
multiple clients or protocols running against
a Wave server, then we could have multiple
transports for the Federation.
>> Yes, okay. Ever applies to the reverse
[INDISTINCT], and somebody had mentioned the
idea of having protocol or service on sort
of [INDISTINCT] server, which would do the
time warp transformation for you or help with
that [INDISTINCT]?
>> LASSEN: Yeah, the same thought occurred
to me that I think that would be--that would
be a sane thing to do. I think it would fit
in nicely with the protocol that it wouldn't
violate any of the principles in there. So
it would specifically save you from transferring
all that data if you just want to transform
that anchor.
>> Yeah.
>> LASSEN: So it's not entirely clear whether
you would want--in all relevant cases, you
would want the data anyway. So you--okay,
probably this for running off but, Scott?
There you are. Please take it away.